so right now we're doing surveillance
flights over Syria where we're trying to
figure out where Isis is on the ground
and what we can do we're also doing
pinpoint strikes against Isis in Iraq
and now the FBI issued a kind of
interesting statement about what's going
on let's take a look it is difficult to
predict triggers that will contribute to
homegrown violent extremists attempting
acts of violence lone wolf terrorists
present law enforcement with limited
opportunities to detect and disrupt
plots which frequently involves simple
plotting against targets of opportunity
so basically what they're saying is
we're doing all this stuff there and
there's a chance that they're gonna hit
us here so we got a theme here of like
fear-mongering kind of stuff but do we
have to worry that any of this stuff is
gonna come here I think we absolutely
have to worry about lone Wolf's I would
be more concerned about people like that
than actual groups over here colluding
to do something you know that's what I
would be more concerned about although
very said Isis is coming through the
Mexican border
that's what he said man that guy I
thought he was in jail actually yeah
yeah but that's what he said um didn't
they find there was an American that was
killed last weekend right who had joined
Isis so I mean I worry that there are
people with American passports that have
you know converted to this horrific
ideology and are now right and then
they're gonna come back I think it's a
you know it's worth looking into and you
know being mindful of yeah so White
House press secretary Jay earnest chimed
in on it as well
we're concerned about the threat that is
posed by ISIL but it is the assessment
as stated by the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff by the intelligence
community that there currently is not an
active plot underway to attack the
homeland by ISIL you know I don't know
when I hear this stuff I kind of think
like remember before 9/11 when everybody
was saying well Bush was warned
resilient Iams
and then another part it's like all
right if they don't know they don't know
I I guess for me it's like I don't know
what to believe anymore
do you do you suffer from some of that -
well I I don't know what to believe
other than the fact that don't believe
anything I think in the last
years with the news media we are talking
early about how everything is isn't
vetted like it used to be and how rumors
can run amok within the news
organization I think you can't believe
everything yeah this is just that like I
turn on CNN and like they got one guy on
one side and one guy on the other and
then they don't analyze what they say
they just say it and then you know
obviously no you're getting out of fox
and you know you're getting MSNBC so
there's just nobody like there's nothing
that I turn on where I'm like oh now I
got sort of like an honest assessment
but I mean that's what I'm trying to do
is some like I don't have all the
answers but we can at least discuss this
in some kind of open-ended way to make
people think or do a little bit of
research but really like how do you go
about getting your information on this
like what you're gonna trust watch the
base stuff obviously yeah you know what
I was watching if you google vici
they've done a fantastic five-part
documentary about Isis where they I mean
like the journalists they have working
for them I can't even imagine like the
situations that they put themselves in
but um but yeah that's I think one of
the best things that I've seen the vice
coverage of Isis and what's going on in
Syria like just incredible you know
scenes of their indoctrination of
children the way they police Raqqa you
know like making sure that the women are
wearing like you know canvas you know
covering everything some of their eyes
like it's it's insane ya feel like I'm
watching an episode of homeland or
something I just started watching that
show that's what it feels like yeah
where where do you stand on like the
airstrikes and all this stuff like are
you cool with it everyone seems to be
cool with airstrikes right now that's
like the cool thing like no boots on the
ground nobody wants that but like
airstrike that I actually am an army
brat so my father has incredible medical
issues due to being in Vietnam he's deaf
he can barely see you know and other
amongst other things and I feel like no
boots on the ground but then it's hard
for me to say we should only air bomb if
we're having such a big discussion about
the Palestinians and the Israelis like
you know I mean we all have an opinion
about that but now let's you know what I
mean let's not even talk about yeah
airstrikes in Syria you know II mean
that's interesting so is that also part
of it that we have such an inability to
have more
in one conversation at a time in America
like we just went through like a
month-long Gaza thing where that's all
everyone talked about now we've that
sort of seems like a ceasefire is gonna
hold as of yesterday so now we can move
on something that's like we seem
completely unable to talk about two
things at once what's that about I think
that we just the Twitter generation we
should combine our conversation with the
Islamic state with our conversation
about surrounding Ebola by dropping
Ebola into you know into the the hive
mind of the of the is I would drop
playstation4 because then you just hook
that thing up and then they have
something else to do or just give them a
lot of porn yeah they're all doing it
for the virgins right right just to show
that they're all just incredibly
sexually for us to porn those terrorists
have access
all right so final thought on all this
ice and stuff is are we just damned if
we do damned if we don't like we [ __ ]
up with the first Iraq war then we
laughed the whole place went to [ __ ]
these Yazidi that were on the mountain
forty thousand them we're gonna get
slaughtered nobody did anything so we
ended up saving them but now more are
being killed now like it's just this
endless like if the US helps it's always
good sort of short-term then we [ __ ]
everything up then we help like it's
just is that it are we just is that our
place in the world forever
I think that's how it's gonna be forever
and less people understand you nothing
is a temporary fix you know I was got to
perform for the troops as a comedian in
Iraq and even then and this was four
years ago as we were out in the forward
operating bases doing comedy you would
be standing nests next to a one or two
soldiers here and there and they would
all say this is for nothing as soon as
we leave this is done yeah and and
that's the way it is in like with my
parents my mother was from Berlin
Germany my father was in the army
she was a war bride it's like we were
there for 30 40 years and that's if
we're gonna do something people need to
understand that's the commitment you
have to make still have like 40,000
troops in Germany now nobody knows why
they're there I don't think
yeah well because I I think and I could
be completely wrong it's like when they
enter this people out or they need to
refuel and a bunch of stuff I think
that's that kind of stuff but I mean
it's interesting to me that people just
don't understand nothing is a temporary
fix yeah you know it's ridiculous well I
think that's a really great point why do
you think the troops knew it four years
ago you know like not that we should
have stayed we obviously can't just stay
everywhere all forever but like why if
troops were talking about it to the
comedian's I feel like it because with
my experience with that and I don't mean
to take so much time but my experience
with that is that you know when they had
these forward-operating bases they did
have people from the community of
participating in the forward operating
bases maybe they helped cook or clean or
whatever they did but it was usually
outcasts from the Iraqi community so so
people the people that were entrenched
within families and with within tribes
that had good standing weren't
participating and when you're an
American soldier and you're seeing the
you know you mean that the outcasts of
their society being like they had the
tendency was it was a lot of gay men or
or women that didn't have good standing
in the community that that were
participating in helping the Americans
you know that's I mean I've never heard
that before that's fascinating my take
on yeah you know so I could be
completely wrong but but for a young
soldier a 22 year old kid from East LA
saying yeah this is silliness this is
silliness it makes you really think God
all this money that was spent here and
all this and if you're performing as a
woman I can say whatever I want to
arguably the strongest physically
strongest the least educated men in our
country and they're so appreciative that
that people made the trip or you can say
whatever you want and then to see a
woman Iraqi woman listening and then put
her thing on and then have to you know
go 50 feet outside the wall and she
can't even look a man in the eye you
know any me yeah it's astounding so I
think if young soldiers can figure that
out the fact that you know politicians
can
it's really amazing to me